صفائح ارضيه تتحرك ومباني ضخمه سويت
بالارض الناس مذعورون صيحاتهم تختلط بصدى
اصوات الاصطدامات والانهيارات مشاهد تحبس
الانفاس وحدث مهول بل كارثه كبرى لم تشهد
مدن البلقان مثلها منذ عام
1926 انه زلزال البانيا المدمر فما قصته
عند فجر السادس والعشرين من نوفمبر للعام
2019 استيقظ الالبانيون على وقع زلزال
عنيف ضرب منطقه دورس الساحليه على بعد نحو
21 كيلومترا من العاصمه الالبانيه تيرانا
شعر السكان في مناطق مختلفه من مدن
البلقان بالزلزال الذي بلغت قوته 6 درجات
فاصله اربع كما امتدت اثاره للبوسنه
وصربيا المجاوره وجنوب ايطاليا وشمال
اليونان
هرع سكان المدينه السياحيه دورس والعاصمه
تيرانا وعدد من المدن القريبه الى خارج
المباني التي انهارت المئات منها فيما بقي
الكثيرون محاصرون تحت الانقاض فهبت
المنظمات المحليه للمساعده قبل ان تنضم
لها فرق انقاذ دوليه من كوسوفو وايطاليا
واليونان ودول مجاوره تم تعليق رحلات
الطيران ووسائل النقل وسرعت السلطات
البلديه الى اقامه ملاجئ للالاف الذين
تجمعوا في شوارع العاصمه حيث تم ايواء
اكثر من 12 الف شخص في مساكن مؤقته وما
يزيد على سبعه الاف في الخيام كما شرعت
الفنادق والمراكز المجتمعيه وصلاه الالعاب
في استقبال العائلات المنكوبه دمر الزلزال
نحو
11,490 منزلا بشكل كامل او جزئي كما تضررت
3121 مدرسه وروضه اطفال حيث قدرت تكلفه
الاضرار
[موسيقى]